donc là hop un petit couché sur la
plaine je suppose aurore boréale
détendent crépuscule voilà c'est ce que
je veux le néant lumineux je fais
vraiment ce que je veux ça me change
complètement l'ambiance de ma pièce est
ensuite j'ai fait un petit coup de canon
studio parce que c'est un peu le bazar
tous ces cartons donc du coup
aujourd'hui on va se concentrer un peu
sur la déco du studio parce que cela
c'est un peu un no man's land il faut
avancer faire tout cas qui peut plus
cool un peu plus sexy et justement
partenariat avec philips
merci philippe et pio physio de
sponsoriser je tiens à vous dire tout de
suite comme ça c'est clair a payé je
vous le dis félix l'envoyé du matos pour
effectivement tenir up à rendre le
studio encore plus beau donc on va se
faire ça ensemble
j'étais content de pouvoir partager ça
avec vous faire de toi je vous montre en
plus que j'ai reçu comme ça vous dirait
ce que vous en pensez si c'est bien
d'éclairer pas bien éclairé alors on vit
tout ensemble
je me poste il je ne sais pas pourquoi
alors qu'est ce qu'on a comme matos on a
on pas vraiment que vous voyez un petit
calepin
mais pour faire des schémas je ne sais
pas un style aussi merci philippe c'est
plutôt cool alors on a quoi comme matos
l'éclairage d'un autre angle souplesse
ultime extensible jusqu'à 10 mètres flux
lumineux élevé 1600 lumens ce plus de
25000 eur25 miller ok yes ensuite qu'est
ce qu'on en voyait étendez votre
philippe fuel actifs et de plus jusqu'à
10 mètres en ajoutant des extensions de
1 m ok cool
yes nickel j'ai compris l'ag de m la g1
m en tout j'ai trois mètres
mathématiques malaise ok un starter kit
whaou
j'ai mis à l'honneur d'ouvrir le studio
ça va déchirer se déchiraient on a quoi
ensuite ici au wpt whaou
ah je déteste ces bêtes de quoi faire
une bonne ambiance lumineuse une le
design est chouette très très épuré une
deuxième c'est cool son petit frère un
site génial se doter d'un interrupteur
ça doit être un capteur de mouvement et
ça c'est peut-être un variateur de
lumière
donc là il ya de quoi faire merci
beaucoup philips là je vais couper le
temps d'installer un petit peu dans le
studio ne sais pas comment je vais faire
donc ça va me prendre un peu de temps et
quelques heures le temps de réfléchir et
de synchroniser tout ça pour vous comme
la vache mais je vais mourir aujourd'hui
or il va plus bon je me remets d'une
crise cardiaque a tout de suite le temps
d'un claquement de doigts et la lumière
fut
ça y est j'ai fait une installer ma
config je connaissais la marque philips
you je savais que les produits étaient
pas cadeau je savais que c'était hyper
intéressante pour la maison connectée
mais à ce point là
la facilité d'installation est ce qu'on
peut faire avec franchement c'est
difficile alors vous expliquer la toute
première chasse et ça c'est farteurs
quitte donc là dedans vous avez quelque
chose qui va vous servir à connecter
directement à votre box pour collecter
l'ensemble en gros c'est un petit peu le
coeur de votre écosystème philips ou là
il ya ma box est là quelque part par ici
vous avez cette petit appareil qui vous
sert de coeur ensuite vous créer un
compte sur le site de philips ue je vous
ai mis un lien dans la description si
vous voulez jeter un petit coup d'oeil
vous créez votre compte il vous
connecter depuis votre réseau local ça
puisse reconnaître votre petit boîtier
vous appuyez dessus ça leur commune et
voilà s'y installer c'est hyper hyper
facile
ensuite ce que vous faites vous avez à
l'intérieur du starter kit trois
ampoules vous installez votre ampoule et
ensuite vous avez l'application philip
sion sur ios et android et là ça devient
un petit régal vous avez juste à
l'ajouter salon reconnaît dans votre
réseau domestique ou dit dans quelle
pièce il est vous pouvez paramétrer
extrêmement facilement tu avoues l'aide
à signer une pièce vous faites ce que
vous voulez c'est vraiment cool
alors du coup ce que j'étais j'ai
installé trois ampoules vous emmène
faire un tour chez moi la toute première
ampoule les dans la chambre de mon fils
elle est juste là là ensuite j'en ai
installé deux autres dans la cuisine au
dessus du bar on a donc ici de petites
lampes qui viennent un peu les
chez-le-bart j'en ai vision une ici et
j'ai mis
la deuxième ici ce qui me permet
vraiment d'avoir une ambiance mais avec
mon application philips rouge pour les
allumer très très très facilement sa les
allume directement donc ça c'est sympa
c'est la base
mais c'est qu'un début et c'est ça qui
est cool ensuite on à lego lego c'est
franchement couleur c'est pas légaux le
lego c'est la go en deux mots c'est
cette petite lampe
alors là les brancher sur le secteur
mais si vous voulez vous pouvez
complètement la débrancher dans le sact
du secteur parce qu'elle est
complètement chargé et vous l'a déposée
ou vous voulez alors ça franchement pour
une lumière d'ambiance pour venir je
sais pas les chiens mur pour faire une
petite ambiance pour mettre comme vous
voulez pour mettre sur achevée
c'est vraiment tout simplement idéal
pour ma part j'en ai deux je dispose une
d'un côté une de l'autre ça va être
amené à évoluer parce que c'est qu'un
début la gueule alors pas côté donc ça
va pas trop en tout cas lorsqu'on prend
du recul ça permet effectivement d'avoir
deux points lumineux dans le studio
viennent ensuite le tour lights trip
plus ça c'est cool c'est un grand
bandeau flexible en led ça c'est un
bandeau de deux mètres faiblissement
voyant plus le vent de 1 m et c'est très
bien vu
bravo je sais pas si vous avez calculé
par rapport au studio parce que de là à
là on a quasiment 3 mètres par un tout
petit peu plus ce qui fait que j'ai
positionné comme ça voyez bon dos à
l'aide là qui va jusqu au fond ça me
permet donc d'avoir un éclairage surtout
le plan for two le bureau tout le plan
de travail
donc ça c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
chouette et maintenant est ce qui est
vraiment cool c'est tout est relié
directement à l'application
j'ai mes différentes langues donc ça
c'est la bandelette que vous avez au
dessus face et les huguenots d'un côté
et de l'autre
donc je peux choisir de les allumer les
états et ensuite pour les 3g différents
précède donc là haut up junkie couché
sur la plaine je suppose
aurore boréale détente crépuscule voilà
je sais ce que je veux
le néant lumineux je fais vraiment ce
que je veux ça me change complètement
l'ambiance de ma pièce est ensuite si je
mens à la customiser les mains voyez
j'ai qu'à naviguer et je mets une
ambiance que je veux je me mets la
couleur je veux je fais comme j'ai envie
et franchement je trouve ça super super
super bien en plus ce qui est bien c'est
vous pouvez paramétrer et pas mal de
petites options c'est-à-dire que vous
avez des routes il vous pouvez
programmer des routines au réveil
lorsque vous allez vous coucher
vous pouvez mettre un minuteur enfin
vous pouvez même faire la luminothérapie
il y a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire avec la jument que quelques
accessoires il y en a beaucoup plus pour
l'intérieur et l'extérieur
mais attendez ça s'arrête pas là parce
que là vous me direz c'est bien beau
tout ça mais j'ai pas forcément avoir
mon smartphone devant rails dans l'appli
pour allumer pour éteindre ça peut être
relativement lourd j'ai cette petite
télécommande
alors allez sur un support à les poser
aimanté directement à l'entrée du studio
de l'autre côté là bas donc vous le
voyez pas ça m'évite d'avoir mon
smartphone allumé j'éteins j'allume ma
distance plus fort - for high loges
baisse ce qu'il exprime par l'ambiance
que je veux ambiance feutrée pas trop
feutré alors ici j'ai quand même deux
gros éclairage sur le côté donc c'est
pour ça que vous avez pas forcément
l'impression que ça change tout de suite
mais ça change
j'aurais pu ensuite sur le bouton ici et
ça va me changer les ambiances à me
changer les couleurs peut faire tout ce
que je veux et franchement c'est c'est
assez incroyable
maintenant on doit franchement j'ai pas
envie de m'embêter j'ai donc un truc en
plus ça c'est un petit capteur de
présence
l'idée c'est que laisse tout le temps
allumé en permanence je pose mon cap
taux représente un facteur de jeu le
fixe pour l'instant il est posé voilà ce
qui fait que j'ai programmé que des cinq
minutes d'absence dans le studio
la lumière s'éteint automatiquement et
dès que je rentre ça ça lui c'est un
capteur de présence à vous expliquer
comment ça marche je pense que vous le
savez ça c'est cool mais c'est pas tout
j'ai fait exactement la même chose dans
la cuisine
hop je prends jean lenne j'appuie ça
m'allume je peux changer les scènes je
peux mettre plus fort - forge fais ce
que je veux ça me change l'ambiance je
peux tu as lease et où je peux carrément
augmenté ça c'est vraiment pratique ça
ce pilote tout seul c'est génial et dans
la chambre de mon fils j'ai installé ce
petit boîtier
c'est un boîtier multi bouton vous avez
donc un seul gros boutons aussi vous
appuyer la 2e 3e 4e
l'idée c'est que vous avez une selle
différentes un éclairage différent en
fonction du mouton ce qu'elle vous
affilier donc c'est complètement
paramétrable pour moi le gros bouton
s'est éteint le deuxième s'allume lui
bien normal le troisième ça met une
ambiance un petit peu plus rouge un peu
plus calme et le quatrième c'est le mode
veilleuse quand il dort la nuit ces vins
d'une petite lumière je mes suis là et
là hop
j'éteins c'est vraiment génial parce que
vous avez une vraie vue d'ensemble sur
votre application pour savoir quelle
pièce est allumée cap s est éteinte
vous pouvez interagir directement dessus
vous pouvez créer des scénarios de
pièces ça s'est vraiment bien son père
mais aussi lorsque vous êtes absent de
chez vous de créer des scénarios vous
allumez à telle heure
signaté leur stand est d'abord un peu
une présence artificiel c'est vraiment
hyper hyper hyper complet vous pouvez
configurer vos pièces vous pouvez
configurer tous vos accessoires vous
faites ce que vous voulez comme vous
voulez franchement c'est vraiment bien
je trouve que là dessus il ya vraiment
un excellent boulot de fait et en plus
ça s'arrête pas là parce que vous allez
également dans google on est là dans
google chrome vous atteignez votre
lumière
choisissez le studio j'éteins up paf ça
c'est un jeu peu le rallumer dans le
studio six bleus bien évidemment peut
lire de la musique mais après j'ai plein
d'autres choses bien voyez j'ai tout
mais l'homme qui sont connectés là je
vois exactement où j'en suis rien qu'à
la commande vocale
je peux le faire ok google et un le
studio et voilà franchement c'est génial
ok google allume le studio je veux adore
ça je sais pas vous mais moi quand
j'étais gamin je rêvais d'avoir une
maison hyper hyper hyper connectés
j'aurai des signes de science fiction et
franchement ça me faisait rêver alors là
typiquement avec une solution comme
celle de philippe sion pour moi c'est
vraiment un rêve de gamin
alors je pars j'en fais pas trop où je
vous assure le fait de l'avoir installée
de pouvoir activer avec les commandes
avec son smartphone gérer sa lumière
c'est c'est l'effet waouh c'est l'effet
waouh on est un peu comme un gamin ça
apporte pas mal de choses parmi vraiment
de de changer l'atmosphère de
l'intérieur changé l'atmosphère d'une
maison d'une pièce d'un salon lorsque
vous avec des ennemis vous n'allez pas
voir la même lumière que lorsque vous
allez manger lorsque vous allez regarder
un film s'est pas remis complètement
personnalisé cette pièce avec une seule
et même lumière ça c'est génial on en
reparlera parce que normand il ya encore
du matos qui doit arriver je suis hyper
content dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est ce que la maison connectée
c'est un truc qui vous botte voyez vous
connecter tous avec google comme google
vous avez aussi la solution d'apple est
pas mal de solutions différentes vous
connecter tout et ça franchement c'est
cool et on va collecter en plus de la
larme ça je vous en parle aussi c'est
une solution de devises on en parle mais
si quelques jours parce que le studio
forcément il faut l'équipe en alarme il
serait temps tout le matos calcite donc
ça c'est cool je gère tout directement
depuis google comme ma lumière met
enceinte connecter mon kicker mon robot
dont je vais parler d'ici quelques temps
là que j'ai eu en test depuis un petit
moment
alors effectivement apprend toujours se
poser la question de la maison connectée
le risque de se faire pirater pas mal de
risques on a déjà parlé de cybersécurité
on continuera d'en parler mais en tout
cas là je suis hyper enthousiaste a
dites moi ce que vous en pensez comment
vous trouvé cette solution pour la
maison connectée
qu'est ce que vous pensez et
vite bien évidemment à les regarder ma
playlist autour de la maison connectée
autour des objets connectés comme ça
pour découvrir encore plus de choses
merci soyez sages fait d'ici 4 jan voss
ciao